[Music]
if you can't choose between spending 30
bucks on ryan the last dragon
or groceries but your kids are still too
dumb for seoul
why not try kung fu panda
prepare for a solid mid-level animated
movie for when you just can't handle
another viewing of shark tale
[Music]
never again and enjoy the entry point
into a franchise that spawned two
sequels
five shorts eight video games two
animated series and a theme park land
because china because china
experience a kid's film that wonders can
fat people do anything of value
as this fat panda named poe is stuck
stuck
not what who maybe remind you is fat
and played by fat joke expert jack black
building the parachute
will inspire wall-to-wall fat jokes that
flabby panda can't possibly be the
answer to
our problem only to spend the last few
minutes proving that a fat guy can do
something other than cook and eat
stop it
[Laughter]
okay i'm sorry but pandas are supposed
to be fat can you imagine a panda with
abs and a v-line
gross or hot i'll have to look into that
laugh along with jack black and all of
his most beloved vocal tics
legend with authentic battle damage
then feast your ears on a buffet of
celebrity voice-overs that kids won't
even care about
in fact does anyone really care that the
snake is voiced by lucy lou
i thought you said you were ready are
you super excited that this is dustin
hoffman grunting
and how much do you think jackie chan
got paid for this or even see his toes
but he will tigress you gotta try this
it's shifu
we got this help her he's too fast come
little one
let's find your mama that's every single
line he has in the entire movie
gestures don't count unless jackie did
his own stunts too
you know what he probably did he's such
a pro
follow along on a standard hero's
journey where poe
starts off as a basement dwelling fanboy
who studies the blade
until destiny leads him to steal a
promotion from a more qualified
woman master are you pointing at me
him now under the tutelage of a ninja
turtle who talks like your aunt's
facebook page
today is a gift that is why it is called
the present
the big paddock will fight the big
leopard over who gets to be the big
dragon
and discover say it with me now that the
real magic was inside him
all along to make something special you
just have to believe
it's special being good at what you do
but nothing really special
hey that's the unofficial dreamworks
mono
so enjoy the first film in a franchise
that's better than it has any right to
be
that may be a total pain by number story
but dang
that pain is super nice looking
[Music]
so nice in fact that it skunked wally at
the annie awards causing disney to
boycott them for 10 years
yeah suck it trash robot
story tenacious chi
less cute than an actual red panda send
nudes
crouching tiger hack the planet monken
master
animal david crossing deadly viper
assassination squad
ian mcgains and turtle super the soul
school of wok
okay why is everyone who's not a kung fu
master a pig a goose or a rabbit
did the animators just start hitting
copy paste it's good to use
just let your soul go
just let it shine through
it's fun to learn because knowledge is
power and power
corrupts so go to school and become
evil something funny